[Musique]
merci merci
c'est qu'elle comble giloul la max ou
comment bernard je suis content j'ai
envie de rigoler sayad eric woerth aura
beau temps soit enfin je me suis dit
alban de footing allemande moscou c'est
le bon moment pour aller dans la rue 5
heures pour faire des frères et je fais
des frères et alors mais de l'autre côté
comme ça
alors comment vous allez bien ces
petites pluies s'est pas vu depuis l'été
reste accroché s'accrocher au micro afin
micro mais ça va tu prendrais une
boisson énergétique j'ai le patin de
pêche les ricains qu'est ce qu'ils ont
ils ont 24 heures chrono mais on a quoi
les 24 arte les gros on est contents de
la voir il fallait absolument pas rater
alors par heure
dans un dock seraient légion étrangère
on s'est rendu compte que la voix off a
sans doute raté sa vocation
ce français de 29 ans s'appelle
désormais polaire il a déjà été
militaire pendant cinq ans dans l'armée
de terre l'armée régulière comme disent
les légionnaires ce matin dans motus sur
france2 quelqu'un propose un juron tu
sens que c'est la première fois en 26
ans le public il à deux doigts de
quitter plateau n'est pas bien voici la
lettre b g et claviers aux vosges et bas
[Musique]
ça part bien aller en reportage en est
tombé sur une fille qui reçoit un cadeau
dans une bibliothèque et elle apprend à
contenir sa joie c'est normal j'ai le
temps de qualif pour un candidat qui
accroche pas d'où vous fait que la
famille de sa femme le prénom de votre
parent oui qui s'il ne pas saluer vous
demander tout ce à quoi ressemble rich
hill en blonde on a eu la réponse dans
les rênes du shopping
il y en a des chaussures là j'ai quand
même un rapport très particulier avec
écailles lt quoi tes vacances d'aller
partie ce faire un bowling et hyper doué
la petite a
[Musique]
la cloche rythmique uni et drôle comme
du bon pain à trop drôle les tubes we
have to get the elephant chaud bon avant
que ça ne sorte dans la presse à
scandale je préfère vous le dire moi
même j'ai regardé questions pour un
champion et toi jenson est aujourd'hui
question plutôt simple pour une fois sur
la télé mais quand samuel etienne donne
la bonne réponse au candidat tu sens
qu'il est pas fan de l'animateur qu'on
cherchait un bien la troisième qui vous
manquait lé là ce futur animateur qui en
94 se fait remarquer dans le public du
juste prix
quelques années avec deux corps
présentait la grosse émission c'est
cyril hanouna sur ces mythes si vous ne
le savez pas il essayait de le coacher
anaïs un panahi ça mais j'ai jamais vu
aucun qui avait autant d'allergie ça
continue dans la boîte
avec dans la cour jal haruka vous tapez
daniel fois que je t'ai new delhi était
mort et pas plus fat chanas nicot un sac
étanche allergique aux insectes aux
fruits à coque
sauf que je colle a jugé que o'neal et a
promis que ça et l'oréal il ya la
lessive je suis allergique au gluten
aussant viken double épaisseur abitibi
je ne tolère pas le dos gergy qu'aux
pompiers volontaires et involontaires de
satisfaction annuelle celle ci vers des
eaux fob je ne supporte pas gilles
verdez automatiquement totalement
d'anaïs et les hyper branchée elle que
des mêmes les signes qui cartonne sur
les ados mabanda vie elle va au ciné
avec siri le week end sur son avantage
au poids c'est dans le but d'écouler ma
fille me fait penser un peu à bella dans
twilight et aux dates et images du
prochain pascal le grand frère il va
devoir gérer un ado qui roulent beaucoup
trop vite en scooter pascalou
[Musique]
on ressent al batha
et un petit drôle toi tu as toujours la
petite chômage comme j'aime les chiffres
comme j'aime les lettres j'ai regardé
les victoires de la musique classique
selon je m'en veux rien dire mais si
j'enchaîne personne du raï cheb étaient
les 25e victoires de la musique
classique et regarder voyez les jaloux
vont maigrir et contrairement à ce qu'on
pourrait croire le public il était hyper
jeunes hyper à fond pour les lutteurs de
la musique classique en un petit peu
triché mais ça nous faisait marrer
regarder
[Musique]
cérémonial est animé par leïla keddour
et frédéric lodéon des frédéric gens
qu'il a eu un crush instantanée sur une
chanteuse lyrique un vrai coup de foudre
mais c'est pas réciproque donc elle le
rembarre discrètement j'aurais jamais
résisté parce qu'avec une voie paraît si
j'avais des pinkerton je serais venu
beaucoup plus tôt un an avant on vous
retrouve les essais sur cérémonie des
globes de cristal tout se passait bien
jusqu'au prix de la meilleure comédienne
mais tout le monde a craché pour noble
est en vga noranda
c'est triste destin lui a alors remercié
ray bitar comprend trois sur la terre de
jaguar muriel robin échappée de près un
grand prédateur c'était moins une
le tout à ça peut être la paix sexuelle
[Applaudissements]
s'est déroulé ce que sur les toits t oh
là là y'a les étoiles et tout tu les
regardes tu regardes la grande ourse
comment ça va monter au dessus des toits
en ce moment comme vous les jeunes
il fait un froid de gueux ouais donc je
mal quoi météo à la carte
ah oui et ce afin record d'audience
aventure comme aujourd'hui oui oui en
effet l'aca battu le record d'avant-hier
nouveau mai soit la carte bim tu
regardes les matchs ont envie qu'il
fasse froid des mains tricolore yatuu
demande tad voiture freine on n'y croit
pas on n'y croyait pas cette émission
début j'aurais pas mis vraiment une
quotidienne sur la météo se mariera ça
cartonnait bravo à ceux qui ont eu
l'idée du homard à vos noms mais sait on
les connaît et faro mais ce qu il est en
train de faire tout rester coi tant
qu'il n'y a pas une émission qui se fait
sans lui quoi ainsi réglé mais ce qu
victorien non tu peux m'expliquer des
chiffres et des lettres
sauf que la bête dans météo la carte il
nous parle des régions mais tu sens du
sont loupés déjà que marine l'animatrice
elle est plus montagne que mr
06 températures négatives même encore
sommaire mer montagne les paysages se
confondent arrive le romejko et là aussi
lent des reportages lui et quand il ya
un an marrant il rigole discrètement
c'est comme un délégué de classe quand
la prof trébuche dernière fabrique
artisanale du cotentin dans la famille
burnouf on et biscuitiers de père en
fils et filles mineures sinon avec ce
froid ce matin en métaux à la carte
devant décidé de nous faire voyager ça
fait du bien de rêver et avant notre
journal du temps c'est au bout de notre
monde que nous partons pour nous régaler
à mon dieu maintenant on va où capable
en nouvelle-zélande aux îles galapagos
au bout de notre monde que nous partons
pour nous régaler dans le finistère
à noter qu'on a découvert une espèce
d'écureuil très chou qui galèrent pour
des cas c'est à cause d'un problème
assez rare chez nous regarder et 201
postérieurs pour faire des beaux mais il
sembla lourties
ces tests ils sont énormes
c'est vraiment c'était pas c'est un
document times higher les empêche de
bouger pas et tu fais ça depuis hier et
déjà comme don c'est pas sans réserve
franchement est-ce et où shell savais
pas que les écureuils vont pas nous
casser les noisettes six arrangeurs un
écureuil mais qu'il ya des grosses
toujours compris le nom c'est choquant
alors c'est vrai mais c'est bon * vous
qui avez travaillé dans java progrès
c'est pas un écran et parce que ces
singes écureuils il a pas une grosse que
bah oui c'est pas la la la la la la
christelle c'est vrai ma gêne c'est
qu'on irait vite de sulawesi silva
excuse-moi camarades a pas deux ben pas
moi aussi j'ai dit allez je sais pas ce
qui m'a pris d'intérieur haut les amis
je suis très content moi je suis hyper
content on a des nouvelles de kallio
qu'on aime beaucoup ici aber regard des
robes geneviève de fontenay garde en
effet elle a récupéré l'émission
culturelle de france télé stupéfiants
celle qui l'animé
[Musique]
j'aimerais bien sûr tf1 regardez gilles
bouleau à la seule journaliste qui quand
elle me une capuche
on a l'impression que c'est ses vrais
cheveux on dirait que ses cheveux
bizarres thierry beccaro et la dignité
les maths en ce moment il prend auteuil
prend des beats dans motus se titille
autant c'est pire dans télématin se vend
il fait plus froid que celui de moscou
de tout le monde si houmad le nouveau
musée des arts décoratifs de paris qui
s'appelle désormais le mahatma d'assez
c'est avant le budget qui va pour je
voulais ça veut dire voilà la météo
je crois que c'est les fidji siècle et
dans la phase d'urgence rade et on suivi
la brigade des stups ont fait une
importante prise de cannabis sérieux
regarde
analyse éventuellement niveau des
masques on s'est dit qu'on a s'est
procuré le vrai sens du tournage
regarder
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
avant les frères la densité des bords on
adore quand tu es là et on en
lithologies gmat idf1 non et si tf1
ah oui notamment l'émission idf1 et vous
c'est un jeu qui a dans l'idée est fin
et vous chaque midi et les deux en fait
ils en sont arrivés à un niveau de vie
se supportent plus austère qui s'écoute
même plus et chacun répète ce que
l'autre dit l'émission elle dont le duel
dur de double du temps juste parce
qu'ils s'écoutent par regarde mais
c'était pas ça s'appelle le touche aux
étudiants mais c'est ça c'est ce que
j'aime c'est pour aller voir au théâtre
de trévise
voilà à ne pas manquer au théâtre donc
très vite demain pas de pluie à prix
réduit fédérer c'est un oeil qui n'a été
trouvé vendredi n'a pas été très con à
dire ce qui se passe en direct même
entre booba et rohff l'ambiance est plus
cordiales jeu qu'on s'en étonne jours
après sa disparition castellet le
scantrad quelque chose qu'est ce que ça
serait quoi
sympa et edf 1 c'est surtout l'occasion
de revoir les mystères de l'amour avec
tous les anciens d'hélène et les garçons
il ya tellement d'intrigués de
personnage tu sens que même cri cri
d'amour
il a du mal à suivre sa propre sélection
c'est arrivé ça s'ils continuent
cependant salée si j'ai provoqué le
sinistre les fait jouer de la personne
c'est pour ça que vous faisiez partie
comme une voleuse sans rien dire en fait
elle était pas du tout alors je ne peux
pas je suis je crois qu'il ya les frères
je mange ça d'après mon chéri tu es mon
cas me jette bien il a un four months
que gilles verdez n'a pas aimé le grand
frère hier il a des choses à dire à
pascal le grand frère hier sur scène ça
après moi ça après tu as compris avec le
concours précieux temps ne passe pas
c'est juste et plus chamarré vrai c'est
comme ça c'était frère j'étais jeune
chammari qu on va dire excuse moi mon
ami ni l'amitié
shamrez meilleur prix en bus je suis
allé avec mon petit cul chamarré tourner
les frères dans les rues de paris qu'est
ce qui se passe avec les braves ancien
abbé ça me fait payer mais il faisait un
peu froid grâce il faisait quand même
froid mais on va dans la rue on demande
aux gens ce qu'ils pensent des
transports en commun parisiens
et pendant ce temps s'habiller à peu
près comme eux c'est pas fils armés
[Musique]
qu'est ce que vous pensez des transports
en commun parisiens les transports
parisiens sont vraiment très efficace
leur réseau est vraiment très ténus et
c'est vraiment super de prendre le métro
le bus à paris et votre sol en pense
quoi
je n'ai pas de soeur première nouvelle
regardez du vrai du faux
gardez ça ça à tous puissent à 19,9 et
la voilà mais tu es une heure sur wii
toujours la presse n'avait qu'à être la
soeur préférée mais c'est ça qu'est ce
que vous pensez les transports en commun
de paris et les transports sont plutôt
bien fait notamment de métro ça c'est
unique au monde il ya plein de
sensations ces pratiques
maintenant c'est vrai que ça fonctionne
pas toujours très bien donc il faut
faire attention se renseigner et votre
frère elle en pense quoi
je sais pas comment ça on est de mariage
à côté d une ambiance de folie malgache
et on va là bas non non mais facile je
vois plus mon frère en fait un super
obligé pouvait faire sans qu'on aurait
fait ressembler de seconde à la télé tu
sais pas chez pourquoi indécent de
famille sous loin d'ottawa était pour
moi aux potes berry tâche et signe en
californie journal foot pour moi ça
compte pas ses mots en français qui
compte clément réglera ça plus tard il
offrait rouge
trouve pas très propres hommes après ces
pratiques c'est rapide
voilà c'est un bon transport' à votre
chat l'on pense quoi ma soeur à la main
square n'a pas fait de salut toi un peu
poilu
je paye tank pas super temps de faire
mon footing et encore tu voyais en bas
c'est l'amazonie
tout s'est aussi fait une raison
l'égérie chez mr tu attends le petit a
donné des nouvelles données nouvelles
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]